you
hi everyone is cherry this is another
group of five puzzles and each of them
it's white to play and it's up to you to
determine the best continuation so go
ahead pause the video so you can find
the best continuation for white okay the
solution to this first one is Knight f5
asking the Queen a question and there's
not a good reply taking the Queen runs
into a million-two with first 97 in
regardless of where the King plays let's
just say h7 rook takes Queen and that's
me the night guarding the key g8 and g6
squares one last thing to keep in mind
is that attempts at counter attacking
with let's say Knight f6 attacking the
White Queen fail to Knight takes Queen
still with check so that's the solution
to puzzle one this key move Knight f5
moving on to the second one once again
white to play pause the video see if you
can find the best continuation ok the
solution to puzzle 2 is rook to g6
pinning the Queen and it may have been
very tempting to play Bishop c4 however
after King h8 and let's say rook f7
black is still there to put up some
resistance after Queen g6 so instead
what is best is rook g6 and if now Queen
takes rook well we get some material and
know now that if King goes to the corner
we get the rook and if bishop locks
would give check with queenie 7 to
follow and then marching the pawn the
black the black rook will have to give
itself up soon enough one last variation
is to know that what do you do after
pawn takes rook well now you give check
on c4 without the pawn on each 7 there
is no King h8 Queen f7 is the only move
and now we don't take the pinch piece
but rather attack it exploit the pin and
now we're just getting this type of
position where it's essentially the
queen versus the rook and white is
winning so I'm moving on to the 3rd once
again white to play pause the video see
if you can find the best continuation
for white ok the solution to this one is
first Queen h8
if the King tries to run away well at
the very least you're getting the rook
and if King takes Queen grab the rook
and regardless of how black interposes
on g8 we're going to give check let's
say let's go with the Queen
we give check and mate right away
and if the knight blocks well still it's
this and after the Queen plays here we
get to pick our favorite way to check me
go with the pond that looks like a good
finish so moving on to puzzle for once
again white to play pause the video so
you can find the best continuation ok
the solution to this one is to follow up
with Knights e5 and keep in mind that if
King BA at the very least we could be
going forward with winning the exchange
maybe there's even something better and
if the King let's say goes to this
square we could be coming over to the a
file if the rook ever blocks well
that'll be run into Queen a6 with meit
to follow on b7 the main thing here with
this puzzle is to know what exactly to
do if the knight is captured the key
thing is rook b3 and now after let's say
King 8 in order to meet Queen a6 with
the block well white still does that and
from here it may have been tempting to
let's say grab the rook but keep in mind
the Knights there to defend the idea
however is to grab the rucksack the
Queen and now follow up with the silent
but best King c2 and there's nothing
that could be done about rook a 1 and
we'll be having checkmate soon enough
this right here is the very key idea the
knight first jumping into c5 knowing
that there would be a follow up Queen
sacrifice and then the silent King c2
with me to follow on a1 one interesting
variation is to know that if the King
from this point plays to a7 king c2 is
still there and if the rook plays to b7
we could still come out to a6 the King
runs away it'll be me with either Queen
takes or rook takes on b7 and still
again if King takes made on a1
so that's the solution to puzzle for
moving out to the fifth and final like
to play pause the video so you can find
the best continuation ok the put
solution to this one is first Knight d7
with check and after King to AE this
might already start to be a little bit
similar to puzzle number one of this
group and that is after Queen takes
Knight well white is up a minor piece if
the Queen is captured we will have a
matin to starting first with rook a for
pond take struck in with a very minimal
amount of material rook a 5 and again a
very similar thing as to puzzle 1 that
will be checkmate so that's all for this
video be sure to let me know down in the
comment section how you did with these
that's all for now take care bye